I want to talk about data validation
which is about presenting data visually
to help people find patterns in data or
better understand data we're actually
using data validation a lot already
so I think if you use the Microsoft
Excel you create some bar charts or line
charts before and you are doing
databization so that's a kind of most
common form
when people have been doing this for a
long time so I want to show you this map
probably it was not called visualization
or data valuation before them so this
has happened in a cholera epidemic I
think was in London they
plotted every case on the map each bar
is one case and that's where the address
that was detected by looking at the map
you can see that certainly is kind of
center of the disease happening and they
eventually located as well with the
water was contaminated that would become
the source of the cholera and all these
are kind of very easy to see
retrospectfully but at the very
beginning when they look just at the
patient and record they just couldn't
figure out what was the problem for a
very long time one of the biggest
changes now lots of these visualizations
are created automatically using
computers obviously in the 1844 sorry
1854 it has to be done manually but and
sometimes I think the 1854 one actually
looks better
the other very common type of and
validation we see a lot now is the
dashboard which essentially just a
collection of smaller or simpler
validations as we're getting more data
and becomes more complex or also depends
on maybe the task we want to address
becomes more complex we need these more
the cholera map is a good example in
terms of you showing one picture of the
data set and and you get a very
important Insight after it and but in
many cases in the actual kind of real
life and it's maybe just a part of a
bigger process and which I would call
sense making so I think usually you
people would focusing on the analyzing
Parts which what the data analysis or
data science is but all other parts are
very important and also sometimes you
might have to get additional information
to help you the process I'm probably
very biased but I think we do sense
making all the time but I think at least
two saying we just do this more often
than you think so the examples
is like a planning holiday and find a
place to live or maybe apply for
University degree so in terms of
difference from data analysis so usually
the goal is not well defined and the
process is very open incense is
explosive and iterative so the kind of a
not very good analogy I use is kind of
the maze you have a clear goal you want
to get into the center of the maze or
you want to find the crime in the tweets
you want to find the degree that you
want to study and but you don't know the
maze so you have to explore feel your
way through hopefully eventually you
would get to the middle and it's kind of
explore process you might have to repeat
the same past a few times before you
find sent the right way to the center
okay and so I have a second example
which is more kind of daily sense making
tasks and here is a find the best
cameras for 500 pounds so the context
will be we just had a newborn baby so I
think we should get a new camera so my
wife gave me 500 pound budget so I need
to say okay what the best we can get and
then you started doing some online
research you might try to see what
experts things and in that process we
might came across some technical terms
you never heard before then you might do
more research just to understand what
those things are for example what are
the micro forces or mirrorless or DSLR
what does that mean it's you probably
not going to finish that in one session
you might say you spend now on it you
didn't quite you make some progress but
didn't find the perfect camera yet and
you wait a few days until the weekend
you want to continue but then that's
often okay how do you continue the
process you did two two days ago and the
typical thing is so if you have a
browser with open 20 30 Windows that's
kind of indication you are doing some
sense making yeah so this is kind of
maybe the kind of more dry part and I
try to kind of unpack this diagram a
little bit okay the shoot boxer means
the things you find interesting you
might want to go back to it and look at
later or in the process say doing the
camera research you might find an
article recommending good cameras okay
you think that something you would say
bookmark in your browser otherwise and
you put into your shoe boxes and then
the yellow one is evidence file so
this is more initially was kind of
created more like an intelligence
analysis context so that's why the word
is but to me it's kind of this text you
highlighted in the browser that's kind
of Nakita information that's important
this is usually after you look at the
things you've collected in the shoebox
and the schema ties you're kind of
starting to understanding the problem
better and what is relevant to you see
and there's a megapixel used for or
maybe the aperture is actually more
relevant in the case you take baby
photos because you need a five I say
faster shutter speeds and that's when
the aperture comes into play and these
are things you kind of learn in the
process as a result of your exploration
and learning and then the hypothesis
part is where you can have come up with
a few models since within your budget it
all looks promising you just need to do
a more kind of detailed comparison
between them and finally the
presentation is explaining not just the
answers but actually the process to
someone else rather than say have the
person to do the same goes through the
same process as you did mostly have to
done manually by the person so that's
something like hoping to support develop
something so so this is kind of a step
towards that goal
which is a Chrome extension and you can
actually download it from the Chrome web
store and play but of the usual academic
software quality so what it does is it
try to
visualize the way you have been
exploring so far as the graph and rather
than say just a list of it's usually
seeing a history but also allow you to
do other things for example you can
highlight images or pictures which you
find important
and hopefully this will be better than
say looking at the 20 tabs in your
Chrome window I call this a tree or a
graph saying on the right hand side and
it can also be a way help you to
navigate back to any previous opened
tabs yeah sometimes even just being able
to tell you that's something you look at
the before reminded you some ways quite
useful obviously this is kind of a
simple example when you get more tabs it
becomes more and more useful for the
particular an extension I just showed so
the currently kind of cover these first
straight boxes but I haven't quite go
beyond say how people understanding a
very complex topics that's still very
much done manually by the user so the
goal will be eventually cover the entire
process so certainly lost Works quite a
bit work needed so if anyone how happy
to do some research or collaborate on
this will be very useful I'm very much
interested to make more this one
available to more people and as I
mentioned this is kind of typical
academic software quality at the moment
so definitely needs a bit more software
engineering or maintenance
red stairs with red and football is
green right it's a terrible example
because you wanted memory you had to ask
for it and release it yourself so
um there are two Primitives here one's
called malloc and malloc says give me
some quantity